do you think that women have an
expiration date on dating
like do you think there's any urgency to
like find a husband sooner rather than
later
um i
i think like i wouldn't like to say yes
but i think so i think yeah even you've
got like the whole you're going to have
more options now than well they say that
men get better with age and women
at some point too but yeah but they say
that that's it you know men are allowed
to be a silver fox whereas women have to
get botox and dye their hair and again
you've got like the whole biological
like it's just like we get we get that
attention immediately so like i remember
being like 15 16 and i was like why is
everyone paying attention to me now you
know braces came off and [ __ ] like and
but like men don't have that like
they're like invisible to the world so
it's like a trade-off yeah so so right
now you there's there are things you've
admitted on this show that you get
special favors and stuff because you're
a young 100 percent
yeah right but men don't get that for
the first half of their lives
so like
people will cry and say it's like not
fair but it's like the most fair thing
ever and it's a very small percentage of
men that actually become silver fox it's
not the majority most men don't even get
half that level of advantage that most
young attractive women have and i think
well then as a man gets older it then
comes to um
what you can provide and an older man
you're gonna maybe assume you've got
more
finances you've got more xyz i don't
know
i think men i actually don't know i find
women a lot more attractive than men
like categorically women are a lot more
picky today over here oh yes yeah
as a man gets older you do just assume
like you're probably going to be more
ahead in your career you're probably
going to be so that yourself is more
attractive but it's i think i think that
like men
i don't know i'm not really attracted to
50 year olds like i think i can be like
i'm not physically attracted to them i
mean mark ruffalo
i would call him daddy any day of the
week what's what's what's the oldest you
would
actually consider for a husband
uh
15 20
years old
no years older
no dislike no no no no like i'm like i'm
25 so maybe 45. so you would consider a
40-year guy seriously for marriage and
so yeah if he had no kids [ __ ] most of
most of them probably have children but
like if you look good no kids
sign me up
how about you
it would really depend because i know
some like men who are post 50 who are
really they're running like iron man's
triathlons so so if they were like they
want to marry you start a life with you
you'd be open to that
you know what i'm gonna be real honest i
would i would be a gold digger if there
is an 80 year old man on his deathbed
who was like
i i i would do it i would do it for that
easy life there's there's there's no
limit age limit for you
i mean realistically yeah there is like
that's me just like
kind of like being realistically i'm
like
oh [ __ ] i don't know because oh there's
a lot of [ __ ] to go in there like even
like health even like how open are they
to travel how committed are they to
their job how like no all those things
are there i'm just saying the age what's
the age limit
i don't know i don't know i don't know
she doesn't know i like i'm trying to
think the perfect age
i prefer guys my age but usually i think
like they're usually more like looking
for something casual yeah so that's why
i like guys in their mid-30s not because
i'm more attracted to them but just
because like they're kind of
like i don't know they're not in like
the casual yeah you know it's weird like
i
can get butchered out here if i say this
um i feel like for a mental thing i
prefer women who are older
to actually talk to on a on a on a
standard basis i'd say is generalization
but then
if it's just casual fun then
to be honest it's kind of if she's
attractive
i have a heart take i think girls peek
at like 18
at the time
yeah
yeah rhodes master says like 22-23 i
think
personally for me
i would
i would say and we're talking general i
would say 24-25 because that's when i
say she's still like if she was hot at
22 she's not going to not be hot at 24.
do you know what i mean but she's
probably more mature and i value that i
think that 18 year olds look the best
because most girls gain no more
most girls don't gain weight in college
i know but they just look like most
girls get like beer bellies
in college i just think i just think
like because i'm at that age where girls
who hit on me are around that age yeah
and i find it weird because they just
look like children to me yeah
whereas i'm like now i want to i want a
woman yeah a young woman but i want a
woman you know what i mean like i feel
like i don't know that's what that's why
it's like
yeah i just yeah i couldn't i could like
i couldn't get a girl who looked
incredibly young looking i'd feel weird
mm-hmm
i know some guys love that [ __ ] but
that's i don't know i don't think i
think 18 year olds nowadays look like
they're 25. oh
i wouldn't go lower than 23 though he
wouldn't go lower than 23.
i remember the day that old guys got hot
it was really weird it was like i didn't
see guys i did it when i was 21 or 22. i
was going on dates with a guy that was
30 and i just couldn't get past it i was
like i can't he's so old
i remember like thinking like
oh he's 30 like that's so old and but
now i remember being like 24 i mean like
are 40 year olds attract our dad's hot
yes oh my god it was a wee it was so
weird it didn't happen till like 24 23
maybe i was like
oh this is strange
this is strange
i have a question for both of you
is there a diff well
what would you say is your
dating age range but then you're
sleeping casual sexual age range
so for me i would personally happily
sleep with someone who was like 21 but i
wouldn't date someone who was 21. i
wouldn't like
yeah i kind of
i look for it all this like it's the
same to me
okay like
i don't know seriously okay no not
seriously like yeah like oh like between
casual and serious
uh
i'd say casual
anywhere between
23 to like
i mean i've dated a woman in her late
40s before so i'd say like 23 to like
48. if we're talking seriously i need to
see what she looks like i need
let me see they won't see it they won't
see i won't show them i want you i need
to see
well that's what because i know that for
a fact they should be hot
if i wasn't going to be serious about
someone i definitely the younger they
are i'm like it doesn't matter
i'm going to keep the mic this way and
i'm just going to hope that you why you
still got it for kip's sake i'm going to
oh is that a
why you still got it why you still got
it excuse me
[Laughter]
is that is that is that a thing don't
guys keep like albums of all the nudes
they have well if i if i end things with
a guy i have to i say to them i'm like
respectfully i would like you to delete
anything i've sent you but
[Music]
i know that i know that until they get a
new phone
or they get oh if they get a girl that's
like i need you to delete this but i'm
fully aware that if i ever send
something i'm fully aware
i'm fully aware that if i send something
to someone
that i'm and i don't advocate for it at
all but i'm aware that one they're
probably going to show some of their
male friends i know that i know that
it's happened to me before that they'll
be like this is the girl i'm sleeping
with this the guy i'm dating i'm well
aware that if i send something that's it
uh it's it goes back to
consequences if i send a nude photo or a
promiscuous photo i am well aware that
it probably will not just stay
in his phone or with him and it probably
will not end
any
[Music]
listen ladies
if you send a guy a nude photo it is on
his phone forever that's all i'm gonna
say and i say this i say this in my
videos
do you guys show each other their
girlfriend's nudes